[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who's a
little prick like pickle rick
in this video we're breaking down
episode a of rick and morty
the new entry is filled with easter eggs
hidden details and callbacks to the
overall low of the show
that means there's a hell of a lot to
unpack from it the episode is called
rick turner friendshine of the spotless
mort which is of course a play on the
film eternal sunshine of the spotless
mind
that movie was about a man named joel
attempting to erase the painful memories
of a relationship
however during the process of this he
realized that he didn't want to forget
about his girlfriend clementine
the film was a very introspective look
at love loss
friendship and confronting one's flaws
which this episode itself
very much carries the theme of in the
movie joel was left on his own
which is when the pain of the past hit
him and in some ways this is muradin
rick
who is left alone in the house after the
smiths go away on a cruise together
we can see summer flicking through
iconic new york locations
including the brooklyn bridge times
square and the statue of liberty
i love how beth very much treats rick
like a kid and tells him no
parties and that she's left emergency
numbers on the fridge
which yeah unless it's something other
than 9-1-1 he doesn't need to know
so i don't know why this stuff always
pops up in movies
rick very much takes a trip down memory
lane in this episode
and the first node to this comes with
the mention of pickle rick before we
meet phoenix person
first introduced in rixie business as
bird person
we learned that rick and bp were
longtime friends that had known each
other for a number of years
bird person fell in love with summer's
friend tammy who he later married in the
wedding squanches
however it was during this time that he
confessed that he and rick were wanted
by the galactic federation
and we discovered that tammy was in fact
an agent she ended up shooting bird
person and later the character was
resurrected at the end of the rickshank
redemption
though tami wanted him to be renamed
cyber bird they ended up settling on
phoenix person
and pp showed up in star mort rick turn
of the jerry
as soon as rick revealed that he killed
tammy the pair went head to head
and there was the classic line in which
rick said he always wondered who would
win in a fight between them
phoenix person said that meant he was
always a bad friend and it was during
the episode that rick also wrestled with
how bad of a father he was
due to creating space beth phoenix
person was taken down
and we saw in the episode that rick had
the character dismantled in his garage
phoenix person lashed out at rick who
decided that he was just gonna wait
until the whole situation had blown over
now just before confronting him rick
pours himself a drink
another character's alcoholism has been
almost non-existent in this season
it has started creeping in the previous
episodes i love the way that he has an
ionic coaster and an ion is actually an
atom or molecule that has an electrical
charge
the computer behind it is super annoying
and it's based on jarvis from the mcu
which we learn later in the episode the
similarities include the blue hologram
lights and
offering people bj's which i'm sure the
pleasure bop version of jarvis
was also capable of now they start the
best friend rejuvenation
sequence where the two can come face to
face with each other
and confront their pasts maybe they
should have just bonded over marvel
because
every everyone loves marvel yet don't
they are you a marvel fan yeah well i'm
doing breakdowns on what if this week if
you want to subscribe
and also yeah smash the thumbs up button
because it low-key helps me out eh now
back in the garage
we see that rick has somewhat
frankenstein bird person back together
and that he has dismantled the robot
body that belonged to phoenix person
he's very much rose from the ashes and
the frankenstein idea can be seen in the
stitches which classically appeared on
the creature
yes another monster is called
frankenstein's monster and that the
scientist is called frankenstein who is
the real monster however
the real real monster is the people who
point out that it's frankenstein's
monster
when everyone knows who you mean when
you just say frankenstein yeah we know
who you mean
now rick also burps at this point which
is something that too has been pretty
absent due to justin roiland apparently
having to drink
lots of sodas in order to build up
enough gas to do it it actually caused
severe stomach issues for ireland
and thus they decided to cut it down
unless it was completely necessary
bird person awakens and calls out and
rick uses a purple crystal
several of which i believe that we last
saw in the opening of episode 1 in this
season
rick ends up injecting himself directly
into bird person
and this could be a naughty inception in
which a similar setup was used to enter
someone's mind
in that film the protagonist cobb was
plagued by visions of his dead wife
much like how big person and rick are
when it comes to tammy
the movie even gives a direct nod to
that with all the characters that we
meet being projections
and how bird person remembers them
rather than how they actually were
the whole point of the episode is about
bird person discovering that he has a
daughter
and therefore this is his reason to
return to his life
there are theories as far as inception
is concerned that cobb is actually the
true target
and everyone is trying to pull him out
of the dream that he's trapped in where
he refuses to leave his wife
we've done a full video on this if you
want to check it out bit of shameless
self-promotion there
but we also discover things about rick
as well in this episode we actually get
a huge revelation which confirms that
our rick's beth died and that he's been
traveling around universes and living
with versions where she didn't
there are variants of rick that
abandoned beth and thus this leaves room
for him to just slide in and take over
that means that morty isn't even rick's
original morty
which is something that's been long
suspected by the fanbase
this explains why rick is so callous and
nonchalant
as he knows that if anything happens to
the version of the smiths that he lives
with
that he can just hop to another reality
however it has been slowly destroying
him inside
as they're not really the vision that he
created rather just shadows of them
inside the dream there are several rules
including that if you die then you die
in real life
which is something that happened in the
matrix inception couldn't really do this
studio being a dream and not a
simulation
and those characters ended up trapped in
their subconscious until they escaped
by doing something that would cause them
to die if it was real after traveling
from a skull into a yoke
we then arrive at the festival that they
first met at
amongst the crowd we can catch a more
glitzy in who you might remember from
episode 3.
no elbow titties though which is a shame
as
you know you gotta love those elbow
titties now instead of saying
hello he comes across his younger self
handing out drugs
and we see how their friendship begins
it's hilarious how there's one alien
that looks like a girl sitting on a
guy's shoulders
but they turn around and we see that
it's just one alien that looks like this
they hop to another memory in a bar in
which the younger vision of rick fights
against his multiple selves
we catch the plan for the battle of
bloodridge being formulated
and here we can see squanchy who appears
later on in the entry
and also geardude whose funeral we visit
rick is found by a younger memory of
himself
and this version ends up traveling back
with rick into his own memories so that
he can live on
during this rick mentions charlie
kaufman the director of eternal sunshine
and throughout it we watch as the
characters hop from memory to memory
much like how they did in that movie we
catch bird person stalking
hey himself and tammy who he cries over
when he remembers
how sexy she was it's just sexy
now he finds the galactic federation
rounding a bird person's people
and we see how callous they are due to
the fact that they keep his daughter in
prison
during the post-credits scene tammy
reveals that she's contained because her
father is considered a terrorist
and therefore it's possible that in the
future we'll get an episode in which he
and rick
bust her out bird person manages to draw
fire away from himself
by pointing out rick to the federation
who is obviously the highest threat to
them in the universe
he's saved by his younger much
friendlier self
who's only this way because beth and
diane haven't died at this point
i love that they use a fake portal as a
shield as it was shown by the younger
rick that these don't actually work
because bird person only saw rick walk
into them and not where they actually
went
they discover bird person in the
federation where his brain has been
duplicated
which seems like it pulls from similar
iconography to killian's mind in iron
man 3.
bird person destroys the location and we
catch the aforementioned battle between
rick and phoenix person
playing out from a brand new perspective
this time rick is the one to destroy him
though
as he of course doesn't remember who
took him down because it was from behind
took him from behind bit hawkwood but
moving on this splits his mind
and transforms some of the projections
into zombie-like monsters that want to
kill rick
they head to the battle of blood ridge
which is pretty much rick's vietnam
in which he and bp fought against the
federation before arriving there they
travel into a ptsd station
which appears in a blink and you'll miss
it moment younger rick is excited for it
as he thinks it's gonna be a defining
moment but older rick says that his
values are wrong because he knows the
horrors there
it's kind of a comment on how war is
often glorified in movies
when it's pretty horrific and not
something that you'd want to go through
however the pain of this memory for rick
doesn't come from the battle itself
but rather that bird person rejected his
friendship at the end of it
though young rick initially loves the
battle this breaks him a bit
and makes him realize why rick wouldn't
return to this
squanchy hulks up and there's a moment
in which rick and bird person shoot over
each other's shoulders
which could also be a nod to the moment
in endgame in which pepper and tony do
something similar
we find tammy in bird person sitting in
a tree
s q u a c h i n g
squanching now tammy is actually pretty
nice in this but it's because bp
remembers her as being kind and loving
rather than the double agent she was
bird person tells rick to eat his
cloaker
which is the urinary tract and butthole
for a lot of vertebrate animals
per person learns of his daughter and he
decides that he wants to live
but the venerations show up once more
and they end up hopping through memories
as his mind collapses
they come across the night that bp and
tammy met when they got it
on his workbench and we learned that
squanchy was squanching in the sun
closet
phoenix pearson and tammy arrive and
she's angered that she had to spend two
years in high school
in order to get close to him they come
across squanchy stand up
and we catch a rick with jewel around
his mouth which hasn't really been
present
in this latest season now he's
devastated he's a memory that sat
through this stand up for nothing
and we also see the formation of the
flesh curtains which was the band that
rick and bird person created
the wedding version of tami arrives and
young rick apparently sacrifices himself
as a giant black molten bird appears
tammy or rather the memory of her
apologizes for turning him into a cyborg
and he very much gets some closure
much in the same way that cobb did an
inception rick returns to his body
and before they can say wake me up
before you dodo
bird person asks rick if he hit his
child so that they could still hang out
rick confirms that he only shared the
info on the baby when it was necessary
to help him survive
and the pair part ways not knowing if
their friendship will be repaired
we end with a passerby that the computer
offered a bj to
showing up with lots of batteries so
that she can escape and basically go and
create an
ultron young rick visits a memory of his
younger self
and whereas rick would normally
terminate this he decides to bring him
to life
and get a beer together which the latter
actually refuses as he doesn't want to
become
old rick lots of fun things going on and
yet a nice way to end the episode that
i think feels like one of the stronger
ones in the series so far
i know a lot of the ones this season
have sort of been meh but this was a
nice little entry that really took a
step back into the past
and brought characters back that i've
been wanting to see for a long time
i think the season as a whole probably
has been one of the weaker ones
but this was definitely an episode that
i'm gonna revisit a lot of times
i don't know if you guys want me to rank
the episodes when it's all over so let
me know
i think this would probably sit in the
top four rather than being in the bottom
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and it was also
my birthday yesterday so just drop just
drop a nice comment please
we are running a competition right now
and giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of august
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the episode you
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now
say that to you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
suicide squad which will be linked on
screen
right now we went over the movie's
ending its post credits scene and what
it means for the future
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sending through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace